vraiment bar l'assemblée lui accorde sa
confiance il invite les français à la
discipline l'objectivité la tolérance
italie confusion et désarroi
aldo moro serait en vie 'l'indice une
nouvelle photo françois ceyrac raymond
barre deux heures d'entretien le
patronat en trois mois les négociations
avec les syndicats
dès le mois de mai et maintenant des
remous au ps des fédérations s'agitent
un commentaire de noël copains mais là
messieurs bonsoir l'italie respire ce
soir en tout cas elles soufflent un peu
elle a la quasi certitude qu aldo moro
n'est pas mort la preuve c'est une photo
du président de la mef démocratie
chrétienne tenant à la main un journal
daté d'hier le quotidien la repubblica
voici donc l'ultime rebondissement d'une
journée de suspense qui avait même
commencé par la découverte d'un corps
dans le fameux lac de la duchesse sondés
depuis deux jours par les enquêteurs
en fait le cadavre était celui d'un
berger italien réputé malade mental et
puis un communiqué numéro 7 a été
diffusée simultanément à thuringe est né
à milan ce communiqué a tout de suite
été authentifiée par les polices et
comme venant effectivement des
terroristes tout ça au milieu d'une
multiplication de messages anonymes
alors faisons le tri victor vraiment et
ne retenons que les certitudes
si samedi prochain à 15 heures nos
camarades qui se trouve actuellement en
prison ne sont pas libérés aldo moro
sera exécuté voilà le team alstom qui
est contenue aujourd'hui dans le viième
message semble-t-il authentique des
brigades rouges qui étaient diffusés
aujourd'hui simultanément à turin à
gênes et à milan mais les terroristes ne
précise pas qui il faut libérer
s'agit-il alors de renato cours chez de
ses camarades qui sont jugés
actuellement à turin
combien de terroristes faut-il libérer
les terroristes disent bien en tout cas
que le soi-disant 7e message qui a été
diffusé mardi dernier et qui annonçait
caldo moreau avait été exécutée que son
corps avait été jeté dans le lac de la
duchesse les terroristes précise bien
que ce message était faux mais pas
seulement faut c'est la démocratie
chrétienne qui aurait organisé
c'est une mise en scène macabre pour
apitoyer l'opinion publique et pour
provoquer un mouvement de répulsion à
l'égard des brigades rouges
cela dit il faut bien noter dans ce
septième message des terroristes
certaines contradictions certaine
obscurité
tout d'abord c'est bien la première fois
que les terroristes demande d'échangé la
vie d'aldo moro contre la libération de
leurs camarades qui sont actuellement en
prison pourquoi ne l'at-on pas fait
avant dans leur sixième message
pourtant les brigades rouges avaient
annoncé que aldo moro étaient condamnés
à mort et qu'il serait exécuté mais même
dans le message qui a été diffusée
aujourd'hui il est dit que le verdict a
été prononcé et qu'il n'est pas question
de le modifier
en somme tout se passe comme si les
terroristes faisait semblant de vouloir
négocier tout en sachant que c'est trop
tard pourquoi parce que la démocratie
chrétienne a confirmé à plusieurs
reprises qu'il n'était pas question de
négocier avec les brigades rouges
voyez cela dit même s'il ya eu un peu de
répit dans la sphère aldo moro les
brigades rouges se montre toujours aussi
menaçante puisqu'elles ont revendiqué ce
matin l'assassinât d'un gardien de
prison
à milan où le voyez c'est le quatrième
attentat revendiqué par les terroristes
depuis l'enlèvement du président de la
démocratie chrétienne
visiblement les brigades rouges qui ont
par ailleurs saccagé un certain nombre
d'endroits publics souhaitent intimité
voilà donc un aperçu du climat qui règne
en ce moment en italie et pour mieux
vous en imprégner nous
nous déplaçons demain une partie de
l'équipe de ce journal pour diffuser nos
informations deux là bas et le lendemain
samedi donc à 12h30
nous diffuserons une heure complète de
rome dans le cadre de samedi et demi
avec de très nombreux documents et
invités en plateau donc demain samedi et
demi également après demain en direct de
rome baisser de rideau sur le débat de
politique générale il ya quelques
minutes à l'assemblée nationale la
discussion sur la déclaration de raymond
barre a été close à 18h30 et dans
quelques minutes vraisemblement on
devrait apprendre les résultats du
scrutin ce scrutin sans surprise puisque
la majorité dans son ensemble devrait
suivre le premier ministre et que
l'opposition devrait refuser la
confiance après tous les orateurs de la
journée d'hier à montbard été remontés à
la tribune pour dire qu à force
d'efforts le pays c'était bien vrai
c'est que la situation économique
s'était améliorée et que cela allait
continuer je disais hier et l'on a
ironisé sur ce propos l'horizon s'est
éclairci oui l'horizon s'est éclairci
parce que certaines transformations qui
aurait bouleversé les conditions de
notre économie sont désormais écartée
parce que nous avons le temps devant
nous pour réaliser les profondes
transformations qui s'imposent à notre
économie
parce que nous pouvons si nous faisons
un effort de discipline mais aussi un
effort d'objectivité et de tolérance
nous pouvons assurer aux français la
dignité de leurs conditions de vie dans
un monde difficile
c'est ce que le gouvernement peut faire
il compte sur ce point sur le soutien de
l'assemblée nationale à vous mesdames et
messieurs de dire si vous voulez le lui
accorder
et bien apparemment ce devrait être sans
problème vraiment baroja la confiance
qu'ils demandent même quelques questions
dans l'après-midi à propos de défections
comme monsieur avait repris sur le mode
il est vrai interrogatifs et non plus
accuser actifs tous les fonctions du
affaire à savoir sur la politique de
défense le rock le régime présidentiel
le scrutin proportionnel elle-même sur
l'emploi qui devrait obtenir une relance
mais dont les couloirs les députés rpr
disait déjà l'an swim méfiance nous nous
ne voulons pas du tout en découdre avec
le premier ministre est ce que pour
autant raymond barre a répondu aux
interrogations de monsieur lieu d'un et
bien il y a répondu seulement en partie
c'est à dire que sur la politique
étrangère et sur l'europe il a précisé
qu'il n'était pas question que la france
samedi que sa souveraineté et en ce qui
concerne l'ouverture
il avait dit que le gouvernement
comptait sur la majorité ce qui
n'empêchait pas le gouvernement
d'écouter courtoisement l'opposition et
même de considérer certains de ces
projets est sur l'album
alors non le premier ministre qui
improvisait a eu la dent
particulièrement dure chaque fois qu'il
ya eu un coup d'accélérateur il a été
suivi d'un coup de frein on ne relance
pas la politique de l'emploi en créant
cinq cent mille projeté de fonctionner
ou en déséquilibre les finances monsieur
françois mauriac disait - lésions ont
des idées et plus ils crient fort et
dans les couloirs gaston defferre pour
les socialistes
et monsieur de prêt ou non pour le rpr
se demandait finalement 6e voulaient
viser monsieur chirac ou tout simplement
monsieur mitterrand vient d'aller d'amd
que vous avez ce résultat vous reveniez
en direct dans ce journal nous donner
j'ajoute que florence d'harcourt qui est
elle aussi intervenue sur n'a profité
pour demander à l'assemblée de moraliser
des campagnes électorales trop dominée
par large
voilà pour l'aspect politique de ce
débat il nous reste à revenir sur le
concret sur les mesures économiques
annoncées hier par le premier ministre
et pour ce faire nous avons imaginé le
personnage d'un monsieur tout le monde
qui va vous faire comprendre ce que
veulent dire ces expressions parfois un
peu technique revalorisation des
prestations familiales des taxations de
l'epargne plafond monde
bon alors s'ils vont lui soucieux ou
réjouit monsieur durand le sera sans
doute successivement dans les prochains
mois en tout cas il peut être déjà
rassuré pour ce qui concerne ses revenus
le pouvoir d'achat de son salaire sera
en effet maintenu et si monsieur durand
fait partie des plus défavorisés son
salaire sera augmenté d'une manière
nette chez les smicards
un million de personnes en france son
salaire augmentera plus vite que les
prix les allocations familiales qu'il
reçoit seront elles aussi régulièrement
réajuster et puis une garantie pour les
monsieur et madame durand qui ont au
moins trois enfants
le revenu familial salaires plus
allocations ne pourra être inférieurs à
3500 francs dès l'année prochaine
garantie encore pour les impôts à revenu
égal monsieur durand ne paiera pas plus
d'impôts que l'an passé et s'il est
actionnaire comme un million cinq cent
mille petits porteurs en france les
revenus qu'il tire de ses actions seront
en partie des taxes et une inquiétude
toutefois pour monsieur durand les prix
les tarifs publics seront fortement
réajuster après le 1er mai 15 %
d'augmentation sont demandés par la sncf
12 à 15 % par edf 10 à 15% par le gaz de
france mais demandez ne veut pas dire
forcément acceptée et puis une grande
interrogation pour monsieur durand les
industriels sauront-ils ne pas abuser de
la libération des prix déjà soir 20h
nous vous donnions toutes les réactions
des organismes syndicale reste à
connaître l'avis du cnps dont le
président françois ceyrac a été reçue
pendant près de deux heures ce matin par
le premier ministre à l'issue des
entretiens monsieur ceyrac s'est montré
satisfait bien sûr du retour à la
liberté des prix qui ne doit pas être at
il dit un prétexte à l'augmentation des
prix puis surtout il a annoncé
l'ouverture dès le mois prochain de
négociations avec les syndicats
nous sommes d'accord pour aborder avec
les organisations syndicales qui nous le
demanderons qu'ils ont déjà demandé des
négociations
nous aurons l'occasion de discuter sur
je dirais les ordres du jour de nos
négociations et ensuite de voir quels
sont les problèmes car si les
organisations syndicales ont des
demandes ou des revendications à
présenter nous nous avons aussi un
certain nombre de sujets qui nous
préoccupent qui touche l'emploi le
financement de leurs régimes de secours
ou de prise en charge du chômage les
problèmes de conception de la durée du
travail ou des garanties de social sur
le plan des salaires minima
professionnel je dirais que c'est
véritablement une négociation
je pense chacun apportera la table des
soucis et les sujets qui le préoccupent
avant de refermer ce dossier cette
question il s'assied ce que nous avons
face à nous le même raymond barre le
même raymond barre d'il ya un an et demi
eh bien imaginez un anticlérical obligé
dont aussi une soutane ou bien générale
qui serait anti militariste et vous
aurez une idée un petit peu de ce que
pouvait penser raymond barre de paix
qu'il était à l'hôtel matignon lui le
libéral convaincu était obligé de serrer
la vis de continuer à surveiller a
contrôlé pour assigner à l'économie
française alors qu'est ce qu'il y a de
nouveau depuis irait bien si les idées
lancées par monsieur raymond barre sont
appliquées l'etat sera un petit peu
moins omniprésent dans la vie des
français
la santé la sécurité l'énergie les
transports ferroviaires et bien c'est
l'état est depuis plusieurs années
l'industrie c'est aussi l'état c'est lui
qui a organisé les grands mariages
industriel c'est lui qui a décidé la
politique en matière de nucléaire ou
bien matière d'informatique
ils bloquent les prix mais il est obligé
de distribuer des crédits et des
subventions
ils contrôlent la hausse du billet de
train ou bien du ticket de métro mais
ils versent chaque année par an 30
milliards aux entreprises françaises en
annonçant que les industriels doivent
être un petit peu plus souvent dans leur
usine est un petit peu moins souvent que
dans les cabinets ministériels et bien
le premier ministre annonce un
changement profond dans les habitudes il
estime que pour faire face à la crise
l'état doit un petit peu moins se mettre
son nez dans les affaires des autres
c'est à dire notamment dans le secteur
privé pour la première fois depuis la
fin de la guerre en france on estime que
le contrôle des prix n'est pas une bonne
chose et qu'il faut le supprimer
bref c'est un petit peu un espèce de zut
à colbert 20 18
vous savez philippe que beaucoup en
écrémant bar s'était inspiré de
nombreuses facettes de l'exemple
allemand en matière de prix de relations
état entreprise de concertation avec les
syndicats
alors pour essayer de comprendre michel
meyer bonne
les allemands ont tiré les leçons d'une
histoire contemporaine émaillé
d'autoritarisme
mais aussi de révolution avortée les
patrons d'allemagne fédérale depuis 45
et avec l'aide bienveillante des alliés
ont par exemple appris à considérer
l'adhésion de leurs ouvriers comme un
facteur plus important que le capital
l'énergie et les matières premières de
leur usine
de leur côté les syndicats ouvriers ont
appris que pour réussir il fallait être
puissant et unis et le poids des
syndicats ouvriers de la société
allemande est elle qui les oblige en
quelque sorte à une co responsabilité
sociale économique qui excluent des
trans idéologique
c'est là à mon avis est très résumé le
secret du fameux consensus social
allemand sur les bases de ce dialogue
entre partenaires sociaux
ce qui n'exclut pas des grèves très
dures comme récemment à stuttgart les
lois du marché de la concurrence
régis de façon quasi absolu la vie
économique
une liberté totale des prix dans un
régime de concurrence sans merci
autant sur le marché intérieur que pour
l'exportation explique une mise en forme
et une sorte de musculation permanente
de l'économie allemande
les canards boiteux de l'industrie ne
sont jamais soutenu artificiellement
dirigisme est un mot banni du
vocabulaire politique et économique
on s'évertue seulement à reconvertir les
sans emploi est allé soutenir
socialement de façon assez exemplaire
c'est là tout le ressort d'une relative
facilité d'adaptation allemande aux
crises économique et du niveau très
faible 3% d'une inflation jugulée par la
concurrence entre les entreprises et non
pas le contrôle autoritaire des prix
un bon chiffre pour le commerce
extérieur français le mois dernier un
excédent de plus de 1000 millions de
francs jean lecanuet va renoncer à la
présidence du cds vous savez que il est
depuis peu président de l'ensemble de
l'udf il pourrait être remplacé par
bernard stasi ou un autre
ce président peut-être y aura-t-il un
congrès extraordinaire pour en décider
edgar faure lui compte se présenter à
l'académie française il a fait parvenir
sa lettre de candidature au secrétaire
perpétuel du quai de conti un fauteuil
est en effet vacants daniel cohn bendit
ne pourra pas encore cette fois-ci
revenir en france c'est ce que laisse
entendre le ministre de l'intérieur
christian bonnet dans une lettre qu'il a
adressée à georges séguy ce que la
général de la cgt avait intercédé en
faveur de daniel cohn bendit maurice
herzog démissionne du rpr l'ancien
ministre et député estime que la
nouvelle orientation du mouvement ne
correspond plus à sa ligne démocratique
et libérale les précisions de jean
philippe lecat le nouveau ministre de la
culture et la communication sur ses
attributions le mot communication at il
dit ne cherche pas à dissimuler la
reconstitution d'un ministère de
l'information mes attributions seront de
caractère technique nouvelle
manifestation des divergences au sein du
pc jacques serait montier qui assurait
la rédaction en chef d'action et la
publication du secteur entreprises du pc
bien jacques stremme entier a adressé sa
démission à georges marchais mais il
n'envisage pas pour autant de quitter le
parti
et puis au sein du ps donc pas des
craquements noliko palmer des
grincements depuis quelques jours vous
dire que beaucoup de textes circulent en
ce moment
oui beaucoup de textes circulent il y en
a aujourd'hui qui fait particulièrement
du bruit sous le titre manifeste 78 78
c'est le numéro du département des
yvelines et non pas seulement l'année
1978 ce texte propose en fait une assez
sévère auto critique du parti socialiste
et je cite il reproche en particulier au
parti socialiste n'avoir pas fait au
moment l'actualisation du programme
commun des propositions offensives
marquant ce programme commun de son
empreinte
et puis il est dit aussi que le
programme commun est considéré comme un
programme revendicatif dont la cohérence
en tant que projet socialiste
n'apparaissait pas claire ce texte
venait des yvelines et l'on pense
forcément à michel rocard il sait le
département de michel rocard et puis
comme il ya eu aussi un autre texte qui
fait parler de lui ces jours ci et on a
des signataires serait patrick viveret
qui est un ami politique de michel
rocard il n'en fallait pas plus pour que
certains pensent qu'il y avait une
opération michel rocard est lancé à
quelques jours de la convention du parti
socialiste il a même eu semble-t-il des
remous au sein du secrétariat national
du parti socialiste
et claude estier aujourd'hui dans son
éditorial de l'unité critique ceux qui
font circuler des textes qui sous le
couvert de casser les courants et sous
courant vise surtout à faire progresser
tel d'entre eux au détriment des autres
alors qu'est ce que l'on sait alors il
fait du côté des militants des yvelines
qui ont participé à la rédaction de ce
texte ont presté on précise que ce texte
a été élaboré à partir d'une réunion qui
était ouverte à tous les militants et
qu'il y à bien d'autres textes en
circulation au sein même de la
fédération des yvelines la mort et 128
ont précise aussi que michel rocard
n'était pas cette réunion et les
militants ajoutent que michel rocard est
assez grand pour se défendre tout seul
alors ce que l'on sait aussi c'est que
michel rocard est absente paris de la
région parisienne au moment où ces
différents textes ont été mis en
circulation
et l'on sait également qu'il n'entend
pas à prendre la parole en public avant
la convention du 29 avril
je voyais le débat est déjà largement
ouvert et animé entre les cours valéry
giscard d'estaing en corse prochainement
il l'a promis à l'un des parlementaires
de l'île jean bozzi la bombe française à
neutrons ce n'est pas sérieux a dit yvon
bourges de mise de la défense yvon
bourges et été entendu par la commission
de la défense nationale de l'assemblée
la politique étrangère maintenant avec
la décision du gouvernement espagnol
d'abolir la peine de mort est de
présenter un projet de loi qui la
remplacerait par quarante années de
réclusion criminelle
l'espagne avait sous le régime
franquiste usé et abusé de la peine de
mort et de cette barbares méthode du
garrot serré autour du cou des points
d'année pour leur briser les vertèbres
cervicales salvador guyane teach
anarchiste catalan exécuté à barcelone
en 1974 ultime victimes du garrot en
1975 les cinq derniers condamnés à mort
du régime franquiste ont été fusillés le
garonnais plus servi depuis dans les
rares concessions qu'il a faites à la
presse
le roi juan carlos a toujours clairement
laissé entendre
l'horreur que lui inspirait le supplice
et de fête
depuis son avènement aucune exécution
n'a eu lieu pour l'espagne qui
s'interrogent depuis plusieurs mois sur
sa justice cette abolition spectaculaire
faisait peu à peu son chemin
la nomination il vit à trois semaines
d'un directeur des institutions
pénitentiaires connu pour ses idées
abolitionniste ne laisse pas de doute je
crois que l'espagne est arrivé au jour
où elle ne peut plus se contenter de
réformes partielles
elle doit rénover ses lois et son code
pénal en profondeur changé réformer et
de fait hier en corse et ancien détenu
le confirment les prisonniers s'infliger
des blessures volontaires pour protester
contre les violences dont il était
victime ici à carabanchel il y à un mois
un prisonnier est mort au cours d'un
interrogatoire alors pour éviter que les
erreurs ne se reproduisent rétablir les
conditions de la dignité la nouvelle
administration veut briser le mur du
silence avoir des interlocuteurs et
pourquoi pas parmi les organisations de
prisonniers cela me paraît nécessaire à
l'intérieur des prisons c'est moi qui
vais voir les représentants des dix
tenues et je discute avec eux à
l'extérieur je crois positif d'avoir des
contacts avec des organisations comme
celles des parents et amis des
prisonniers telle qu'elle existe en
espagne
seize mille cinq cents détenus dans les
prisons nombre d'entre eux le sont au
titre d'un code pénal jugé déphasés par
certains de ceux qui sont chargés de
l'appliquer la volonté de changement se
manifeste ici encore mais à abolir la
peine de mort et à vouloir faire entrer
la démocratie dans les prisons avec tant
d'urgences la nouvelle espagne gagne
encore en crédibilité en europe
désormais seule la france la belgique et
la grèce n'ont pas aboli la peine de
mort le fils de sitting bull fils du
fameux vainqueur du général custer il ya
un siècle vient de mourir règles sacré
céder son nom avait 121 ans
on le suppose le dernier grand sachem
des sioux était venue en france il ya un
an
invité par une famille passionnée de
tout ce qui touche à l'histoire du far
west et à l'époque nous l'avions
rencontrée
cent vingt ans c'était donc l'âge
supposé de holly eagle aigle sacré jams
de son prénom
lorsqu'il a été filmée par antenne de
l'année dernière plus que centenaire en
tout cas il était et c'était son premier
voyage en europe
enfant il avait vécu quelques-uns des
grands événements de la résistance
indienne
il était déjà née lors de la bataille de
little big horn où son père sitting bull
avait vaincu le général custer en 1867
il voulait jusqu'au bout assumer son
rôle de dernier sachem déçu on est
honnête un langage que l'on aurait pu
croire extrait d'un film de western
si j'ai la possibilité de parler au
président carter je m'assurerai que les
traiter avec les indiens soient
respectés ce désir qu'il applique
quelques unes des promesses faites aux
indiens même avant sa naissance comme
tant d'autres indiens avant lui au
l'eagle fils de sitting bull aura donc
vécu en comptant sur les promesses des
grands chefs blancs l'état nous doit
encore 6 millions de dollars disait-il
il est mort dans un hospice le garçonnet
de 6 ans disparues hier soir dans la
banlieue lyonnaise a été retrouvé ce
matin sain et sauf le petit malik était
séquestrée dans une baraque d affecter
non loin du domicile de ses parents
on cherche un suspects mais on n'en sait
guère plus ce soir sur le front de la
marée noire maintenant puisque nous
avons promis de vous donner des
informations tous les jours pour ne pas
oublier un problème qui nous a tenus en
haleine
un mois après la catastrophe et bien la
pollution semble avoir diminué au large
mais elle persiste sur les zones
côtières telles sont les conclusions de
la troisième campagne d' analyses faites
par les spécialistes pour mesurer
l'évolution de la pollution marine de
navires du centre national
d'exploitation des océans ont procédé
pour la troisième fois à des
prélèvements d'eau et de plancton tout
le long des côtes bretonnes et au
tournoi sans profondeur de l'eau
distance à la côte degré d'exposition au
vent autant de facteurs qui expliquent
en partie la diversité des situations
ainsi en baie de saint brieuc les tâches
d'hydrocarbure ont disparu et en surface
la teneur de l'eau est normal en
revanche la pollution persiste en baie
de morlaix de lannion dans les
échantillons de sédiments analysées
la présence d'hydrocarbures est plus
forte dans l'ensemble le long de la zone
côtière comprise entre portsall et
roscoff aucune amélioration mais en mer
d'iroise le degré de pollution reste
très faible
dans tous les cas il faudra se livrer
périodiquement à bien d'autres analyses
pour connaître plus précisément la
nature d altération durable des cycles
de la vie marine
mais tenter de sauver la mère ne suffit
pas il faut également protéger la terre
des quelques 100 mille mètres cubes de
déchets qui s'accumulent çà et là une
série de dispositions nouvelles viennent
d'être mises au point pour mieux faire
ça ce sont difficiles problèmes
déstockage et d'élimination oui tout ça
souvent dans des conditions
d'improvisation avec tous les risques
que cela comporte il y a des exemples
choquant sur le littoral de la bretagne
de la bretagne nord mais nous aurons
l'occasion d'en reparler
safran c'est michel laurent qui a
remporté la flèche wallonne la grande
classique ardennaise avant lui seuls
français à réussir cet exploit il ya 15
ans raymond poulidor poux est un bel
exemple pour le champion de bourgines
michel l'ordre
on avait un peu oublié que poulidor il
ya 15 ans gagner des courses et qui
n'étaient pas toujours l'éternel
deuxième mais on était loin de penser
qu'un français en portrait aujourd'hui
la flèche wallonne une course 10 et on
fait pour les belges et c'est vrai
pendant longtemps on a bien cru que
pollentier le champion de belgique
arrivent à premiers à verbier mais
finalement c'est michel laurence dominé
nettement baronchelli cuiront knetemann
pollentier cuyper dit m
rien que ça une victoire étonnante qui a
surpris laurent en personne
c'est à dire qu'elle me donne dans un
sens c'est d'avoir gagné au sprint ne
m'aurait pas étonné d'avoir gagné
détachées car je me sentais très bien
tout a failli coupe mais vous savez je
suis un piètre sprinter français jamais
basse des hommes comme sur honnêtement
les compagnies j'étais bien très bien
passé quand tout mais qui a attaqué j'ai
fait rouler qu'hubert ce n'était pas moi
faire une forte je n'avais pas
d'équipier je me suis resté rares ou un
cutter et qpr a bien emmenées bien
emmenée ensuite sur aux attaques et je
me suis trouvé dans les roues
relativement facile mètres de l'arrivée
j'ai dit mais je vais devoir les doubler
je vais pas rester là et je suis pressé
cagnotte prise et je croyais pas mes
yeux un croyant pays comptant en
football ça ne marche pas très bien en
ce moment pour deux des équipes les plus
en vue parmi les nations qualifiées pour
l'argentine veut parler de l'allemagne
de l'ouest tenant du titre à la perdu
devant la suède
et puis du brésil qui n'a pu faire que
match nul contre l'angleterre pour le
dernier match de sa tournée européenne
angleterre brésil mais d'abord patrick
allemagne de l'ouest suède et un but
réussi par bono qui place les allemands
sur un bon rails meli larsson maillot
jaune allait être le grand bonhomme
c'est ici lui qui a centré le malheureux
russe man arrière central de l'équipe
d'allemagne fédérale n'ayant d'autre
ressource que de marquer contre son camp
au grand dam du gardien de but du bayern
de munich et de l'équipe d'allemagne
mayer
loool et vous ce sont des choses qui
arrivent sur deux corners les suédois
allait faire la distance
d'abord lee larsson
et encore lee larsson après un premier
renvoi du capitaine allemand vox sur la
ligne 3 à 1 déjà battu par les
brésiliens les allemands ont du mal à
conserver leur titre en argentine le
brésil lui aura du mal à être champion
du monde s'il joue comme il a joué hier
contre les anglais à wembley
chicherit mauvais coups s'outiller passé
et heureusement aussi un très joli but
de l'ailier droit gilles les anglais
méritait au moins le match nul
grâce à ce coup franc de keegan ils vont
l'obtenir
voici le doux visage de daniel brême
j'imagine que c'est pour donner les
résultats
il y avait 4 159 votants donc demain
jour de 457 exprimer il ya pour 260 et
contre 197 et 2 abstentions
il nous manque quelques voix à la
majorité oui non parce que il ya 24
ministres et il ya mois pour permettre
aux super fier j'ai donc c'est tout à
fait logique
on râle compte voilà à bien merci
beaucoup alors on vit un petit pot sport
si l'on peut dire avec ses deux élèves
parachutistes qui s'entraînent très
consciencieusement avant de faire le
grand saut où les reconnaîtrais dans un
instant ce sont les deux fils aîné de la
reine elizabeth d'angleterre le prince
charles
et puis son frère cadet le prince andrew
une préparation très sérieuse où voyez
vous voyez un peu avant que c'était pas
à l'envers
durel métier de roi et durer son
apprentissage
regardez les sauter il saute pas de bien
au 1
voilà il y avait un tiercé aujourd'hui à
evry voici la combinaison gagnante 4 le
9 et le 10 8
vous découvrez avec moi les rapports
dans l'ordre un peu moins de 30 mille
francs et dans un ordre différent un peu
plus de 5000 francs la météo de demain
vendredi et remis le journal le ciel
restera très variable avec des averses
sur l'ensemble du pays seuls quelques
exercices produiront sur les régions
méridionales en revanche de très
nombreuses averses sur la moitié nord du
pays
températures stationnaires 20h45 c'est
patrick lecocq qui vous présentera le
dernier journal mais auparavant je
propose de rester en compagnie de
françois truffaut et de virginia
crespeau veulent comprendre pourquoi
oui en effet en scène de ce soir le
grand plaisir de présenter à ses
téléspectateurs l'un des derniers films
de françois truffaut histoires de
village
alors bien évidemment nous allons parler
de l'histoire d'aller large que ce que
c'est le film que nous diffusons sport
est tout d'abord puisque vous êtes là
françois truffaut merci d'être venu
faudrait et satisfaire une petite
curiosité personnelle
vous avez commencé en tant que critique
de cinéma vous livrez vous êtes devenu
le metteur en scène de renom que l'on
sait est alors de plus en plus le grand
public commence à vous connaître en tant
que acteur de cinéma lors sont trois
choses différentes 3 métamorphose
comment est ce que vous êtes passer de
l'une à l'autre de six étapes et
pourquoi peut-être oui je ne sais pas
vous savez acteur metteur en scène c'est
un peu complémentaire parce que on peut
quelquefois avoir envie de jouer dans
son propre film un des rôles où le rôle
principal même éventuellement oui mais
là une grande production qui ne vous
engagez en fait et en vue de noms en vue
d'accords dans le terreau le principe le
film américain c'était une participation
exceptionnelle parce que j'aimais
beaucoup le metteur en scène qui faisait
ça qu'il avait besoin d'un français qui
préférait même un français qui ne soit
pas un acte et critique la danse est
l'activité la moins intéressante parce
que je pense que je critique c'est quand
même le monde dit l'inspecteur des
travaux finis voyez c'est pas très
créatif
quoique ça fasse partie aussi il faut
bien des critiques de théâtre des
critiques littéraires si des critiques
de cinéma mais mon activité principale
c'est la mise en scène et je suis
content de montrer ce soir ici à
télévision
ce film l'histoire d'un village qui est
ancien déjà de trois ans les trois ans
et vous avez dit que vous étiez à fidèle
à vos acteurs comme rémy
conserver une équipe d'acteurs que vous
connaissiez travailler avec eux alors on
a vu jean pierre léaud dans de nombreux
personnages masculins claude jade
d'héroïne de plusieurs de vos films
alors là pour à des lâches appareils
isabelle adjani pourquoi pourquoi
isabelle adjani c'est un rôle bêtement
qu'elle ne pouvait pas jouer jean pierre
léaud néant le vénère dis moi même nom
le tchad c'était une histoire d'amour
qui demandait à un visage nouveau
isabelle adjani est presque la seule
française dans ce film au milieu d'une
troupe anglo saxon le film a été tourné
entièrement en l'île de guernesey et
voilà c'est une histoire de passion
c'est une en général on a des histoires
d'amour dans le cema et plein
d'histoires d'amour à deux personnages
et cette histoire là m'a retenu surtout
parce que au fond on y voit un seul
personnage vibrer vraiment avec passion
l'autre n'est que sortes de prétextes
presque le bel âge ans d'histoire c'est
un amoureux tunisie puis j'aime les
meurtres aux amarres la chambre vellave
dernier film les idées 6 les obsessions
voilà c'est ça mais il est des gens que
plus rien ne peut faire dévier de leur
trajet affectif et puis il ya une raison
pour laquelle il a pour le dire c'est
que vous êtes tellement vous-même
méticuleux voudrais souhaiter voir un
petit peu comment ça allait se passer la
diffusion de votre fille vous avez monté
tout à leurs hôtes et les cinémas où on
regarder dans quelles conditions ça va
se passer
oui parce que j'ai remarqué que les la
télévision ce qui passe quelquefois un
peu moins bien sont les scènes de nuit
évidemment dans ce film qui est une
histoire d'amour une histoire de passion
et très intime beaucoup de scènes se
passent la nuit parce que si je voulais
que le film soit mystérieux il ya un
mystère dans le film
à tel point que je vous ai pas dit voyez
l'identité exacte d'un des lâches que
connaissent ceux qui ont déjà vu le film
ou ceux qui ont lu beaucoup d'articles
mais peut-être pas tous les cinq ans
marc parent là et alors
comme il ya beaucoup de scènes de nuit
je voudrais que vous fasse très bien les
réglages
et du côté des téléspectateurs leur
demanderai je n'ai absolument pas
d'ordre à donner des mêmes de conseils
mais quand même de ne pas regarder un
film en pleine lumière et d'éviter qu'il
y ait des lumières qui se refléterait
sur l'écran du récepteur il faudrait
idéalement voir le film dans les mêmes
conditions qu'au cinéma en éteignant
enfin avec le minimum de lumière et nous
notre côté au télé cinéma nous
essaierons de régler le mieux possible
leurs noces de scènes de jour et de nuit
et on va pas faire attendre davantage de
spectateurs mais avant tout je voudrais
leur signaler que leur programme privé
ne sera pas néanmoins terminé après la
diffusion de l'histoire d'adèle h il y
aura une émission de la série légendaire
vers 22h10 une soirée merci françois
truffaut